Paul Campbell is a real estate agent
from Canada who has a very peculiar way
of getting things done in fact he is a
cheat he never repairs or amends the
properties he is about to sell and just
covers them with various objects
unfortunately for Paul most of his
clients catch wind of the deceit and
leave within the first five minutes this
has made him a very unsuccessful real
estate agent because of which he and his
family are forced to live a very modest
life with no luxuries whatsoever sounds
like a Canadian to me one day as he
returns home from work he learns that
his beloved uncle passed away on one
hand Paul is devastated by the loss but
on the other hand he is ecstatic as the
uncle was a millionaire with no other
relatives this means that Paul is going
to inherit all his property however when
he meets his uncle's lawyer he learns
that the old man actually donated all of
his wealth to charity all he left for
his nephew is a small plant frustrated
and annoyed Paul takes the plant with
him and heads home the next morning
during breakfast Paul is still in a bad
mood he chastises his kids for spending
too much money when in reality they have
barely spent twenty dollars this week it
is revealed that Paul has never given
them pocket money because of which they
have started disliking him that's not
even enough for a fortnight skin Dad
after breakfast Paul clears the
storeroom in his backyard and places the
plant there he is still angry at his
uncle but also decides to show some
respect by watering the plants and as
soon as he does so surprisingly a 100
Bill pops out of it Paul quickly plucks
it out and stares at it in disbelief
this is when he realizes that the plant
is not an ordinary one but an actual
money plant as Paul tries to find out
more about it his family suddenly
arrives there however instead of showing
them his new find he changes the topic
and sends them away it is apparent that
he doesn't want his family to find out
about his money plant the following day
when Paul returns from work he nervously
heads to the storeroom to check if the
plant has grown more money to his
Delight thousands of dollars are hanging
from the plant in this way Paul
continues harvesting money from the
plant while also hiding it from his own
family one day an old man named Tim
arrives at the door claiming to be his
deceased uncle's best friend he requests
a small donation for his organization
and Paul who is in an extremely good
mood writes him a check for one thousand
dollars this surprises the family and as
soon as Tim leaves they confront Paula
but his Newfound wealth however instead
of revealing everything honestly he once
again lies saying that he has been
selling a lot of properties as of late
as the days pass Paul becomes a rich
person he has now started wearing
designer clothes ditching his worn out
and ragged outfit he also gives both his
children 200 as pocket money whoa screw
skins now we can buy an actual good game
this creates a very happy environment in
the house for the first time in years in
the next scene we see a totally changed
Paul he no longer cares about petty cash
and is always looking for ways to spend
more money in one instance he buys an
expensive lawnmower although his house
doesn't have much of a lawn in another
instance when his work colleague Jack
makes fun of his old car Paul gets angry
and ends up buying a sports car however
he makes the mistake of paying
everything in cash because of which the
car dealer becomes suspicious believing
that Paul is involved in illicit
activities he quickly informs the police
about it car dealers are snakes they
would never do that soon detective
Miller arrives at the scene and takes
all the information she can from the car
dealer when she puts two and two
together she also deduces that Paul is
involved in illegal stuff so she makes
it her mission to catch him red-handed
meanwhile Paul heads to his workplace
and shows off his expensive car to Jack
and you thought I had a small pee pee
Jack when the latter inquires how he
could afford it Paul says that his uncle
left him a lot of money as an
inheritance following this he heads home
and surprises his family with the car
while the children are over the moon
with the new purchase his wife Grace
starts becoming suspicious she requests
Paul to honestly tell her about the
source of income but just like the last
time he ignores her over the course of
the next few days grace continues asking
the same question but Paul always finds
a way to ignore her this causes the
couple to have minor arguments one
morning the old man Tim once again shows
up outside requesting a donation however
Paul who is now in a bad mood sends
Tim's ass away rudely after he leaves
for the office detective Miller arrives
at the house and interrogates Grace she
inquires about her husband's line of
work and despite all the arguments as of
late Grace defends Paul she mentions
that he is an honest and hard-working
real estate agent who has never done
anything illegal realizing that she will
not get any help from his family
detective Miller decides to take matters
into her own hands she conducts a
thorough research on Paul's profile and
learns that he hasn't made a single sale
in the last month this makes her even
more sure that he is involved in
something wrong meanwhile Paul's Life
Starts spiraling out of his hands
because of the constant nagging he
suffers at the hands of his wife Grace
demands to know where he gets all his
money and slowly but steadily even she
starts doubting his conscience to make
Matt is worse the plant also stops
giving out cash assuming that someone
has cursed him Paul hands out money to
all the people who may think badly of
him he also goes to Tim's office and
gives him a huge donation he simply
wants to lift the curse so that his
plant can once again start functioning
but Tim who has been impressed by the
real estate agent's attitude shares with
him some words of wisdom he asks Paul to
share his wealth with the ones in need
claiming that it will bring him
happiness and satisfaction Paul likes
the idea and to start off with he dumps
some more money on the desk before
leaving unfortunately just after a few
minutes detective Miller arrives at the
scene and notices the large amount of
cash lying on Tim's table this makes her
assume that the old man is an associate
of Paul and that both of them are
dealing in illicit stuff that night a
Sleepless Paul heads to the storeroom
and tries every possible way to revive
the plant at one point he even reads the
Holy Bible hoping that God will help him
out unfortunately all his efforts are in
vain the next morning Paul heads to a
cafe and buys a takeaway coffee for
himself on the way out he runs into a
homeless man and gives him a 100 Bill to
continue his Good Samaritan gimmick he
also gives away his coffee to make sure
the man doesn't stay thirsty
unfortunately right after he leaves
detective Miller again shows up she
spots the homeless man with the cash and
assumes that he is helping Paul
distribute narcotics in the area hence
she apprehends him without giving him a
chance to speak elsewhere we learned
that Paul was supposed to attend his
son's all-important football match but
as usual he left Tom without informing
anyone this has left his son very
disappointed and angry currently Grace
is trying her best to contact Paul but
he just won't pick up when nothing works
she along with her daughter Carrie head
to Paul's Factory to look for him the
place is dark and gloomy with no signs
of any workers around as Carrie enters a
shady looking room she accidentally
falls through a hole that had been
covered by a cloth turns out Paul was
supposed to fix it but he simply hid the
hole to save time now his own daughter
has paid the price for his negligence in
the next scene where take into the
hospital where it is revealed that Kerry
has suffered a fractured arm Paul's
colleague Jack is furious at him for
always slacking at work and being
Reckless he almost ends up punching him
but backs out at the last moment and
leaves later Paul also realizes his
mistake and starts weeping in front of
his wife all his life he has used
shortcuts when he should have done
things in a better way this is the only
reason his family has always been on the
back foot being The Good Wife that she
is Grace forgives him for everything and
asks that he'd start a new that night
Carrie is finally discharged from the
hospital and everyone finally breathes a
sigh of relief Paul also makes amends
with his son by promising to always be
by his side and never abandon him again
he is now finally realized that family
is more important than anything else in
the world Paul promises to be a better
person from now on however the very next
morning detective Miller arrives outside
his home and arrests him as Paul is
taken to jail he is shocked to see the
homeless person from earlier Tim is also
there and he finally reveals everything
he mentions that he knows about the
money plant in fact he he was the one
who discovered it in the first place
when Paul's uncle was going through a
hard time Kim gave him the money plant
hoping it would solve his problems
however the exact opposite happened with
more money there came more greed and
Paul's Uncle started falling into an
even dangerous hole of depression but
with some guidance and counseling he
totally turned his life around he
started using all his wealth to help
those in need and this ultimately made
him happier then he died after Tim
finishes narrating his story he urges
Paul to do the same that is to always
help others around him a while later all
three of them are surprisingly released
from jail it turns out that Jack told
the authorities that he and Paul became
massively Rich after they sold a large
property in New York but in reality it
was only Jack who conducted the whole
deal he simply lied to the cops to save
his friend with this detective Miller is
left with no evidence against Paul so
she stops investigating him once and for
all you heard it kids if you get in
trouble for lying just lie again the
following day Tim's organization holds a
small function and Paul's entire family
is invited turns out to be a Homestay
for orphaned children who have no one to
look after them Tim was collecting the
donations to help continue this project
soon Paul is invited on stage and with
all the experiences he has had he
delivers an emotional speech at first he
declares that he will sell his sports
car and donate all the funds to the
organization he also vows to always help
the children in one way or another
earning himself a round of applause from
all the attendees in particular his
family and Jack are greatly impressed in
the final scene we see Paul and his
family heading out for a vacation as of
now he doesn't have a lot of cash like
he used to when the money plant was
delivering but at least he is happy and
that's all that matters Paul shakes
hands with Tim and returns him the money
plant as he knows now the actual value
of life he then gets into his car and
drives away with his family making for a
happy ending subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching